[Music]
amanda's in nashville hi amanda welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world
um
not a lot i just had a quick question
and i wanted to press this by saying
that i do follow your plan but i've been
trying to diagnose the medical condition
for the past year so i do have a larger
savings than you would approve of
um my question is should i refinance my
house to pay off my student loans or
should i sell it pay off the mortgage
should pay off the student loans and
then rent until i can buy again my
husband and i
okay a lot going on here how much is
your student loan debt 137.
what's your degree in
uh my husband is a chiropractor i'm a
medical assistant
okay and what does he make
he makes around 110 i think is it your
student loan or his
it's his
oh
okay
he makes 110.
all right
and um
interesting
and you make how much um i make
somewhere around 30. but the household
last year i think we brought home 122
not mistaken
this year you have 130 000 in student
loan debt
yeah 137 137
okay and 63 and savings all together so
you not being able to work is not going
to
because the your income is a the smaller
portion of your household income right
yes and i um
you that have a medical condition or him
it's him oh it's him
oh
so yeah we're both able to work so
you're piling the money up because
waiting on what this diagnosis for him
might be what
what has he got
what's going on with him
um i'd rather not say it's just
something that we've had to do a couple
of diagnostics on in the past year
okay well depending on how debilitating
it is and how sure
the diagnosis is correct is
uh the more debilitating and the more
sure you are the more i'm just selling
the house
i'm not refinancing and borrowing your
way out of the debt either way
yeah our thought process there was that
we would be able to lower the interest
rate
it's not an interest rate problem it's a
debt problem
okay
and you have a huge pile of debt so if
you sold your home would it pay off the
student loan and the home
oh yeah everything and you'd be free
okay
so if he's not going to be able to earn
that kind of income to be able to pay
off
the student loan
by being a chiropractor that he took out
getting kind to they took out to become
a chiropractor because of this medical
diagnosis yeah you need to sell the
house
to reset and to get yourself positioned
to weather this health storm
okay now the the other question is this
um or the other thing to bring up and
because i
you intentionally are
i've got an incomplete picture because
you're
concerned about privacy and that's okay
all right
but let me give let me give you two
other pieces of information that might
enter into this
when is are these uh
federal student loans
uh yes they are right now okay well they
need to stay federal student loans
because if he were to pass away they are
forgiven
okay well it's not anything that serious
this is more of a yeah
if he were to be declared permanently
disabled
that's not going to happen either okay
so it's not that extreme okay that's
good yeah and that's nothing extreme
good okay so you're going to pay them so
the only question is how long is he
going to be with and you got you just
you guys have to assess this
the longer he's going to be out of work
or have
hugely diminished income the more i'm
going to lean towards selling the house
but if it's a one-year thing and you
want to hold on that's fine hold on put
the student loans on hardship deferral
come back from the mess and get the
income back up and attack the student
loans and get rid of them i'd be okay
with that yeah i think the other factor
here is how expensive could the
treatment be i felt like there was a
little hint towards that and that's why
i'd still sell the house set you free
you got plenty of cash plenty of freedom
and income to be able to pay for the
treatment well when you come back and
you're making you're making a hundred
thousand dollars again
after the other side of this and just
buy another house i agree that'd be an
okay thing to do too